bei uns sind seit wochen keine
intensivbetten frei wir machen betten
frei wenn ein patient auf die
intensivstation muss aber alle betten
sind wenn sie verfügbar sind und
betrieben werden können belegt wir sind
auch schon in der situation dass wir
tatsächlich den ganzen tag
koordinieren telefonieren wie wir
patienten in thürigen zentral verteilen
und auch im gespräch mit anderen
bundesländern also wir werden wieder wie
um den jahreswechsel sehr bald in die
situation kommen dass wir patienten aus
thüringen andere bundesländer verlegen
werden müssen und wenn sie davon
sprechen betten werden frei gemacht hat
auch die frage an sie wie machen sie das
wenn wir eigentlich keine sind ja gar
keine frei wie schaffen sie das ja es
gibt sogenannte step down bitten in der
medien kerr betten wir werden dann immer
die patienten die am besten sind die
nicht mehr beatmet sind die von der
kreislauf funktion so weit stabil sind
dass sie nur noch überwacht werden
müssen im überwachungsbereich
verlegen und dann halt entsprechend
schwerer kranke auf die intensivstation
aufgeben also ich höre sie priorisieren
ja jetzt schon irgendwie ein bisschen
ihre hilfeleistungen und auch nach
kapazität und arbeitskraft kann man da
jetzt schon von der tria sprechen der
sogenannten oder ist das noch zu früh
nächten preissituation sind wir nicht
ich befürchte allerdings dass ich mit
meiner 30-jährigen berufserfahrung der
intensivmedizin das zum ersten mal
erleben werden könnte es ist aktuell so
dass wir in der intensivmedizin
in einer exponentiellen
wachstums funktion bei den belegten
betten sind wir nehmen jeden tag in
thüringen der größenordnung zwischen
sechs und zehn patienten auf und die
verweildauer ist zwischen zwei und drei
wochen dann muss man einfach
extrapolieren und man sieht also auch
was wir in den letzten tagen gesehen
haben die wachstums funktion ist
bedrohlich und wir haben aktuell ein
drittel aller intensivbetten den
thüringen mit kobe patienten belegt die
wir betreiben können das heißt aber auch
es gibt regionen wo 70 bis 80 prozent
der patienten corona patienten sind auf
der intensivstation wir übernehmen
aus ganz thüringen patienten wir wollten
heute einen patienten aus meinigen
übernehmen konnten allerdings nicht mit
dem hubschrauber die verlegung
organisieren weil nebel thüringer wald
war also es sind schon wirklich auch
weite strecken die wir hier zurücklegen
müssen um die patienten adäquat zu
versorgen
vielleicht muss ich hier auch mal kurz
aufgreifen es gibt ein paar im stream
die behaupten dass viele patienten auch
aus dem ausland behandelt würden könnten
sie das vielleicht mal aufgreifen und
uns vielleicht mal berichten wer also
bei ihnen dort auf stationen liegt in
den intensivbetten da gab es auch
übrigens die frage wie alt die
patientinnen und patienten denn sein
also sie fragen kann ich sehr gerne
beantworten also es gab eine anfrage vor
etwa zehn tagen
anders rk ii inwieweit wir bereit sind
patienten aus rumänien oder
aus slowenien zu übernehmen ich habe für
thüringen hier absagen müssen obwohl ich
der meinung bin dass wir gut beraten
sind solidarisch zu handeln wir haben
eben gehört das aus bayern patienten
nach italien gehen wir kommen langsam
aber sicher in die situation dass wir
solche ausgleichsmechanismen nutzen
müssen und solidarität funktioniert
immer in beide richtungen das rk ii hat
aber thüringen auch in anbetracht der
belegungssituation auf den thüringer
intensivstationen nicht als zielort
gewählt die situation ist in den alten
bundesländern und insbesondere auch im
nordwesten der republik noch entspannter
und diese kliniken haben hier primär
auch patienten aus rumänien übernommen
das ging auch über eine überschaubare
anzahl von patienten also wir sprechen
hier von 18 patienten
aber zum beispiel hilft die bundeswehr
in anderen europäischen ländern bereits
gerade in osteuropa auf den
intensivstationen aus auch wir waren um
den jahreswechsel dankbar um die hilfe
durch die bundeswehr auch auf unserer
intensivstation und es ist durchaus
denkbar dass wir auch auf diese
ressource wieder zurückgreifen müssen
bezüglich des alters der patienten kann
ich ihnen sagen dass das maximum der
patienten das jetzt bei uns auf der
intensivstation
behandelt wird im zeitfenster im
altersbereich 50 bis 70 jahre alt ist
wir haben eine 29 jährige patientin auf
station und wir haben einen 83 jährigen
patienten auf der station
aber das gros der patienten ist zwischen
50 und 70 und auch die frage an sie dich
schon an die kollegen aus bayern
gestellt habe weil das kam auch immer
wieder in den fragen wie sieht's denn da
aus mit dem verhältnis geimpft nicht
geimpft jetzt ist auch die impfquote in
thüringen eher niedrig wie sieht das der
aus sie waren heute morgen noch bei der
visite
ja also heute morgen bei der visite habe
ich zwei geimpfte patienten mit
durchbrüchen gesehen und 15 nicht
geimpfte patienten
ich kann aber auch noch mal was er
später gesagt hat nur bestätigen die
verläufe bei und durchbrüchen sind
milder bezüglich der lungen beteiligung
als bei ungeimpften und es ist eine
frage der wahrscheinlichkeiten sind
patienten mit
schweren begleiterkrankungen
die hier eine nur unzureichende im kant
wort aufbauen können zum beispiel
patienten mit bösartigen tumoren gerade
solche des blutbildenden systems oder
patienten mit einer immunsuppression wir
haben patienten die
zum beispiel organ transplantiert sind
dann kann aufgrund der immunsuppression
wie im antwort nicht in der weise
ausfallen ich habe in meiner ganzen
erfahrung bei über 370 patienten die wir
auf der intensivstation mittlerweile
behandelt haben hier im klinikum noch
keinen in ansonsten gesunden patienten
gesehen der nach einer impfung
einen durchbruch hatte mit dem versagen
wie gehen sie und ihr team damit um wenn
jetzt jetzt quasi in eine situation
kommen wo der großteil der menschen in
den intensivbetten nicht geimpft das
macht das frust bei den kolleginnen und
kollegen die ja wie geht es ihnen damit
ja man muss als
pflegekraft als mediziner in der lage
seien hier auch sich frei zu machen von
weltanschaulichen betrachtungen es ist
trotzdem ermüdend und vor allen dingen
ist es halt auch ethisch so wie sich die
situation auch in thüringen entwickelt
eine echte zwickmühle wie man in den
nächsten tagen und wochen mit der
situation umgeht
der deutsche ethikrat hat unter anderem
auch schon durchaus solche erwägungen
wie den impfstatus
hier auch einfließen zu lassen in die
entscheidungen durchaus diskutiert gott
sei dank sind wir noch nicht in dieser
situation noch können wir über ausgleich
mit anderen bundesländern nachdenken nur
bei ungebremster entwicklung und
deswegen hoffe ich sehr dass die 2g
regel auch konsequent umgesetzt und
kontrolliert wird ohne dass wir diese
welle brechen werden wir in eine
situation kommen wo wir ganz
schwierige entscheidungen treffen müssen
die ich in 30 jahren intensiv medizin
und nicht treffen musste
ulrike bei youtube fragt sie gerade
angesprochen die zwei gericke bei
youtube fragt sich welche maßnahmen
wären notwendig um dieser entwicklung
entgegenzuwirken reicht zweig zweig plus
denn aus und da auch noch anschließend
auch die frage von dennis lange der sich
fragt was können denn bürger tun ganz
konkret was für maßnahmen damit sie der
krankenhaus belegschaft helfen können
also ganz konkret der wissenschaftliche
beirat der landesregierung in thüringen
empfiehlt zweig plus maske so stets auch
in der verordnung des landes drin das
heißt auch geimpfte können den virus
weiter geben also ich glaube dass wir
uns an zweig plus maske
nun müssen für die nächsten wochen wir
sollten große veranstaltungen die zu
super spreading events werden können wir
kennen das aus ischgl weekends aus
heinsberg aus gangelt
karnevalsveranstaltungen
können zu absoluten super spreading
events werden also auch da sollte man
einfach mit einer gewissen
bereitschaft auch zur reduktion solcher
events und ereignisse
sich wappnen und ich nochmal der appell
ist es ganz klar impfung ist der weg aus
der krise auch wir haben
limits bei der verfügbarkeit von
impfstoff wir haben mehr personal in den
kliniken die geimpft gepustet werden
möchten weil sie jeden tag mit solchen
patienten zu tun haben als wir momentan
im slots anbieten können für unser
personal daran arbeiten wir mit
hochdruck aber impfen ist der weg aus
der krise und bis dahin reduktion der
kontakte zweig und maske das sind die
akuten möglichkeiten die wir haben und
natürlich jetzt auch für uns akut der
bedarf auf die solidarität anderer
bundesländer auch zurück zu greifen
und sie haben natürlich jetzt als die
menschen die da unmittelbar ganz nah
dran sind nicht die möglichkeit sich da
irgendwie zurückzuziehen sie sind dem
ganzen ja unmittelbar ausgesetzt wie
schaffen sie es denn ihre belegschaft da
ehrlicherweise auch noch zu motivieren
jetzt im zweiten corona ja da wirklich
dabei zu bleiben
also wir sind in der glücklichen
situation zwei psychologinnen auf der
station zu haben die ganz
engagiert sich um die belange der
angehörigen unserer patienten kümmern
aber auch um das personal das ist eine
ganz ganz wesentliche hilfe
dass man wenn man überlastet ist sich an
professionelle hilfe wenden kann wir
haben auf der anderen seite auch eine
zunahme des krankenstands im
pflegerischen im ärztlichen personal das
ist eine extreme belastung situation die
jetzt schon so lange anhält und die
verlässliche
einhaltung von bestimmten spielregeln
auch die
ja die
möglichkeit die pflegepersonal
untergrenzen verordnung einzuhalten auch
wenn es wehtut die betten zu sperren und
dann halt ganz konsequent zwischen
kliniken patienten zu verteilen das sind
aktuell wirklich wichtige strategien wie
das schlimmste verhindern ich schaue
noch mal in die kommentare es gibt
sicher auch noch einige fragen die ich
hatte auch eine 1 kommentar gesehen er
ist mir vorhin durchgerutscht da auf
jeden fall sprach man ihnen dank aus
allen medizinischen kräften das würde
ich natürlich weiter geben auch wenn ich
leider nicht mehr finde wer es
geschrieben hat aber jetzt nochmal zu
euren meinungen und fragen es gab hier
noch ein bisschen allgemeine
fragen und ich versuche mich hier durch
also es gab auch noch mal hier eine
frage von civ player bei youtube der
sich fragt warum kommen unsere
intensivbetten eigentlich an die
belastungsgrenze bei einer inzidenz
zwischen 250 und 300 während in
großbritannien seit wochen die inzidenz
um die 400 liegt und ich dort nichts von
träsch wäre also warum sind bei uns denn
die intensivbetten an der
belastungsgrenze
also ich kann ihnen ganz sicher sagen
und ich habe sehr gute einblicke ins
englische system mein bruder ist seit
über 20 jahren in england als arzt tätig
ich habe gute freunde in london
sie kommen in england überhaupt nicht im
altersklassen in denen bei uns noch in
intensivbehandlung
selbstverständlich erfolgt auf eine
intensivstation im inland die
wartezeiten in england auf eine
operation zum beispiel auf eine planbare
operation werden momentan im
täglich zunehmendem maße nach hinten
verschoben ganz extrem in london können
sie unter umständen 12 14 16 stunden in
einem rettungswagen warten bevor sie in
ein krankenhaus kommen also zu glauben
dass in england wo es altersgrenzen gibt
wann noch eine dialysebehandlung
begonnen wird etc
dass dort nicht reagiert wird ist
einfach unwissenheit oder mangelnde
kommunikation ecmo therapien werden dort
oft schon bei altersklasse 45 oder 50
jahre abgebrochen das heißt nur bis 45
oder 50 können sie in einzelnen kliniken
diese therapien kriegen in deutschland
können sie auch mit höherem alter noch
mit einer maximalen therapie rechnen es
ist wirklich nicht so dass es in england
keine tricks sondern in england ist die
triage ein täglicher standard
es gibt noch mehr fragen jessica medi
fragt wie ist es möglich dass wir höhere
zahlen mit impfungen haben als letztes
jahr ohne impfung
ja das ist ganz einfach eine frage der
statistik wenn sie in dem maße wie wir
aktuell kontakte haben und da können
sich jeder selbst an die eigene nase
fassen und sich auch mal
gucken wir haben vor bisher um die
gleiche zeit viel viel weniger
kontakte gehabt als wir es dieses jahr
haben wenn sie jetzt in eine bahn sich
setzen in dem ece diese vollen züge die
gab es voriges jahr um diese zeit nicht
wenn sie gucken wie man sich trifft in
restaurants zusammentrifft wie man in
den entsprechenden sozialen kontakten
wieder normal unterwegs ist dann ist das
ein ganz großer verdienst der impfung
also man sollte das auch nicht
kleinreden und sie sehen es halt auch
wenn sie die individuelle korrelation
zwischen impfquote und belegung der
intensivstationen innerhalb deutscher
bundesländer oder auch zwischen europa
ländern das haben wir in ihrem bericht
ja auch gesehen vergleichen dann ist der
zusammenhang eindeutig
ich habe hier noch zwei fragen kann ich
auch gut zusammenfassen hier wird so ein
bisschen die frage gestellt was es mit
den bundeswehrkrankenhäusern und was es
auch mit zivildienstleistenden ob die
nicht als helfer herangezogen werden
könnten um sie zu unterstützen
ja wir mobilisieren
aktuell auch wieder mann und maus man
darf das system nur nicht
überstrapazieren wir können nicht
einfach sagen durch mehr personal das
wir irgendwo her mobilisieren können wir
die komplette einschränkung dieser
infektionen ersetzen sie dürfen auch
nicht vergessen wer bei uns auf der
intensivstation behandelt wird der hat
ein ganz hohes maß an
leid und an belastung auch zu ertragen
wir haben eine sterblichkeit in der
größenordnung von 30 bis 50 prozent bei
diesen patienten viele patienten die
nach wochen oder monaten auf der
intensivstation
nach hause gehen sind nicht mehr die
alpen sie haben von longkou ried gehört
sicher alle es gibt persistierendem
probleme es gibt einfach schwere folge
zustände man sollte nicht glauben dass
die infektionen wenn man nur genug
intensivbetten hat etwas ist was man
einfach so zur kenntnis nehmen kann das
ist eine sehr große belastung für die
patienten und es ist mitnichten so dass
das also spurlos an einem vorbei geht
wenn man die erkrankung überlebt